l'imprimerie de dammartin-en-goële où
s'étaient retranchés les terroristes les
frères kwasi ouvre ses portes
aujourd'hui
puis d'un an et demi après l'attentât de
charlie hebdo une inauguration en
présence de françois hollande prioris il
est partout et que nous devons lutter
lutter avec la force lorsque c'est
nécessaire je parle de la force armée
lutter aussi avec l'esprit avec les
idées entendez vous autoriser les mères
à disposer de l'identité des personnes
habitant leur commune et inscrites dans
le fichier
j'ai l'impression que pour un certain
nombre de collègues ce n'est pas une
rentrée c'est une sortie au regard de ce
que sont ces fiches et de la nécessité
de préserver la confidentialité la
transmission des listes de personnes s à
ce jour est juridiquement impossible le
coup de déprime c'est vous c'est vous
qui leur rappelait à tous les moments
qu'ils ont à coup de déprime moi quand
je les voyais n'ont pas de coût des
primes ils sont combatifs
donc la seule chose que j'ai à faire
c'est de gérer les journalistes qui leur
disent tu nous écoutes des peines
il ya quelque 70 députés socialistes ont
déjà annoncé qu'il se représenterait pas
écoutez madame la sénatrice ne remettait
pas en cause ma parole de cette affaire
là ou alors on rentre dans un autre
débat
et moi je vous parlais d'alstom
précisément sur chacun des dossiers
alors vous qui l'avez vu travailler mais
il a été surcoté il est surcoté banal
mac os je crois que quand du parti
d'aller c'est comme un certain nombre de
dossiers en suspens c'est un autre débat
blâme la sénatrice et vous avez un autre
comportement quand je suis à strasbourg
à ce moment là vous avez un autre
comportement dont ne soyez pas
différente à strasbourg est ici pour des
raisons de basse politique ne peut pas
voir le discours à paris un discours à
strasbourg forme de double discours
c'est dur quand même vous titiller un
petit peu j'ai vu qu'il était très
énervé par cette question
il ya un petit milieu des charentes avec
du pâté de harengs donc là c'est dans
l'après-midi la même devant la bassesse
même devant l'outrance même devant la
calomnie
même devant la trahison on ne recule pas
je le regardais là pendant votre
reportage ce sens qu'on trouve que qu'il
n'est pas en paix qui n'est pas apaisé
qu'il ya quelque chose de 2 voilà du je
sais pas comment vous dire ça super six
colloques mais je trouve qu'il n'est pas
en paix le 27 octobre
il y aura un gros problème car le maire
de bordeaux favori des sondages a prévu
de longue date un meeting à marseille
il se trouve que nicolas sarkozy compte
en organiser un le même soin et juste à
proximité
la politique la guerre des clans qui est
la guerre des clans qui se poursuit
entre deux affaires
cette façon à la guerre des clans
partant clos marine le pen n'aura pas
fait l'effort de rassembler son propre
camp
elle ne constituera pas pour moi comment
dirais-je est une candidate indiscutable
marque puis si de l'autre côté il ya des
électeurs du front national qui tout
d'un coup chemise quand surgissent ce
parti nous amène dans le mur
et bien moi je n'exclus personne dont on
vous rassembler on ne commence pas par
exclure nous attraper faudra d'abord
nous aborder aux ischios papillon